[MUSIC PLAYING]
RACHEL LEVY: What to expect
during today's session--
we're going to talk a little
bit about the business
drivers of why Discover
Financial chose
to pursue a virtual
assistant, ways
to mitigate negative perception
of AI and enterprises,
and the process
Discover developed
for building and
deploying virtual agents,
as well as ideas of metrics that
should be captured to ensure
virtual assistants
continue to be adding value
to your organization.
So, a little bit about Discover.
Discover was actually
my first customer
I worked with when I came to
Google about 14 months ago.
And I walked into the
meeting after they
had done a bake-off
for NLP tools
to help with a
virtual assistant.
And I walked in, and
they seemed really smart.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
Like, if all customers
are this smart,
my whole job is
going to be, like,
the easiest job in the world.
And it turns out that
wasn't entirely true,
but working with Discover
has been really fantastic
because they use really
intentional decisions
and careful processes for
enabling technology that
enhances the customer experience
across their enterprise,
as well as with their
external customers.
And they are also pushing
boundaries and stretching
the capabilities of what
the virtual assistant
and Dialogflow can do
with innovative approaches
to testing metrics and
deploying the agents
across the enterprise.
So I'd like to welcome up
Price to talk about it.
He's a senior business manager
for digital automation.
PRICE VETTER: Thanks, Rachel.
So as she said,
I'm Price Vetter.
I lead automation in our
digital servicing channels
here at Discover.
Quick obligatory
legal disclaimer--
there we go.
So, a lot of people
think of Discover
as mainly just a
credit card company.
But we also offer a slew
of banking products--
checking and savings accounts
to personal and student loans.
But really, our goal is
to help people achieve
a brighter financial future.
And really, that means that
we put the customer first
in everything we do,
from the processes
we have in-house to the products
we deliver to our customers.
So a little bit more about us--
we're available in
190 plus countries.
We have 15 network
partners around the globe
in China, India, Japan
Africa, South America,
just to name a few.
But we have over 100 million
touch points or interactions
with our customers to service
their accounts annually.
And that's supported
by over 8,000
of our customer service experts.
In the digital space
specifically, we've
had 12 years of experience with
messaging with our customer
service experts.
And as that channel has matured,
we've seen explosive growth.
And just over the
next five years,
we're expecting a 60%
year over year growth
in those digital channels.
So really, we're looking
for ways to support that.
And so we came to the
conclusion that we
needed a virtual assistant.
But we don't think of it
as a cost cutting measure
per se, but more
of a way to deliver
a service that our customers
really are looking for.
Our customers really
want something
that they can get answers
to their questions
as fast and easily as
possible with every brand,
not only Discover.
So that was the
original, I guess,
driver behind why we decided
to go with a virtual assistant.
But not only that, we're
seeing some really great,
I guess, lift with our agents.
They're able to handle the more
emotive, complex conversations
now, which enables
them to really have
a better interaction and
touchpoint with our customers.
And then finally,
because of this,
we're able to kind of
deliver new capabilities
for the channel, things that
we weren't originally thinking
about.
But how did we get there?
Many people within
our enterprise
have a perception of AI.
You can thank Hollywood
for Terminator,
for Robocop, for HAL 9000.
You can thank PR disasters
for Twitter bots and stuff.
And that's really
what people think
about when AI comes to mind.
What they don't think about
is what they interact with
on a day-to-day
basis that is AI--
spam filters, voice
assistance, maps.
And so we really
had to ground them
in what was reality versus
what they perceived AI to be.
And we also had to make
them more comfortable
that we were actually putting
the customer first and thinking
about how we introduced
AI to Discover.
So for example, we
disclosed, if you will,
that our customer is interacting
with the virtual assistant
every time.
And then if we do end up having
to transfer that conversation
over to a customer service
expert, we tell them as well.
So it's a transparent
experience for our customers.
When we rolled out the
virtual assistant, though,
we had to really
think about how this
would affect our customers.
And we also had to
think about the best way
to define value for each of
the intents or inquiry types.
So we looked at the
volume in our channels,
for instance, to understand
what the most high traffic
intents were.
Once those were defined,
we went and defined
kind of a happy path
for the customer,
looked at areas where that
conversation might break,
and really figured
out the best way
to communicate
with our customers
for each of these
intents or inquiry types.
Once we were able to deploy or
develop and deploy an intent,
we still have to make sure
that we're legally compliant.
We're checking all the
boxes with risk, et cetera.
But then once we launch,
we don't just leave it
and walk away.
We're in the channel
constantly monitoring
our customers' interactions
with our virtual assistant
and making sure if
there's better ways
to communicate with the
customers, better ways
to improve the kind of flow
of the conversation, ways
to improve our models
by introducing new train
phrases, et cetera.
And then-- oh.
And now I'm going to show you
a quick demo of just a sample
interaction with what we've
been able to develop over
the past year.
It's just going to show
a sample interaction
with a customer on
our website, and then
moving to the mobile
device while maintaining
that same conversation
across channels,
and then transferring over to
an agent when the conversation
gets a little more complex.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you noticed we don't
build in a delay or anything,
any fake typing bubbles
for the interaction
with our virtual assistant.
That's really to
show that we're not
trying to deceive or make
sure our customers are aware
that they're
actually interacting
with a virtual assistant.
With that, I'm going
to turn it over
to John to kind of talk about
how we've utilized Dialogflow
and what we've
built on top of it.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN COYNE: Thanks, Price.
Everyone, I'm John Coyne.
I'm a software
engineer at Discover.
As Rachel mentioned,
early last year,
we performed a thorough
evaluation of different NLP
providers, where we
ultimately decided
to go with Dialogflow
to implement
our virtual assistant.
We then spent the remainder
of the year building
out the platform and the
necessary automated processes
to deploy our assistant.
So today, I'm going to cover
some of the building blocks
that you can use and some of the
performance measurement tools
to confidently build and
deploy a virtual assistant.
So during our evaluation
period, our primary goal
was to measure the performance
of intent detection.
So what's an intent?
Quite simply, a user
question or intention.
And really, it's the first
and the key step to building
a virtual assistant.
If you break down a virtual
assistant into two high level
components, it's detecting
what the user wants
and helping them
fulfill that intent,
or what's known
as a fulfillment.
Now we actually
have a separate team
that manages more of the
fulfillment side of things.
And that's more procedural
nature, where you're basically
going out to fetch user data or
performing an action on behalf
of the user.
Where the intent
detection side is
where more of the AI and machine
learning comes into play.
And that's what my
team focuses on,
and that's going to be really
the theme around my talk today.
So for those who aren't
familiar with Dialogflow,
let me explain
some of the basics.
A Dialogflow agent is a
logical representation
of a virtual assistant.
To your agent, you add
a number of intents.
And then to each intent, you
add a set of training phrases.
The training phrases
are then basically
used to customize
your model that's
really built on top of
Google's underlying NLU models.
They're built from
years of experience.
So your training
phases really should
include examples of
how a customer might
phrase a specific question.
For example here, I have an
intent called available credit,
where a customer's asking--
their intent would be inquiring
about their available credit
to spend, is what it is.
And yoy can get
some of this data
from actual customer messages
that you would either sanitize
or anonymize as part
of your input to this.
One of the important features
of Dialogflow that we liked
was something called confidence.
Essentially with
each intent detection
that Dialogflow performs,
it returns you back a score
to indicate how confident it
was in that intent it just
detected.
And this was really
important to us
to be able to make
intelligent decisions
about our virtual
assistant replies.
Dialogflow allows you to
set a minimum threshold,
that if this confidence score
does not meet that threshold,
they can do one of two things--
return you back a fallback
intent or no intent at all.
A fallback intent
can be something just
like a clarifying
statement asking the user
to reword their question,
but this is something
that we decided not to
implement because really, it
was more important for us
to be able to get it right
and try to automate it.
And if you actually notice
here, something that we do
is we set our minimum threshold
extremely low, just 10%.
Now it doesn't mean
that we're actually
sending the replies back to
users in all the scenarios,
but what we're doing is
we're collecting data around
on the intent detection
process, so we
can make more informed decisions
about how we want to really
send our replies back.
And I'll touch on this
a little bit more later.
So the testing process
that we established
during our evaluation
period is something
that we've actually built
into our daily process
as we're adding new intents and
we're updating existing ones.
To start off with, you
have to scour for real data
from customers, whether it
be from existing IVR channel,
chat, or it could even
be inbound email channel.
But you might really have to
spend some time to actually get
good labeled data.
So here's a customer message,
and here's what intent
you expect to get back.
And something to
know is you want
to make sure that your
training data that you used
for the train phase is
separate from your testing data
because you don't want your
results to become biased.
So when you have
your labeled data
with a message
and an intent, you
can send it through
the Dialogflow's API
to detect the intent.
You get back a name of an
intent, along with a confidence
score.
And then from there, you
compare it to the [INAUDIBLE]
and expected intent, and you can
generate a set of core metrics.
Now we do this on
a per intent basis.
Essentially for each intent
that we have defined,
we go through and calculate
each one of these metrics.
So giving a couple examples,
if a customer said,
why is my credit showing
at $0, if we detected this
as the intent available
credit, and we
expected to get
available credit,
then while we're calculating
available credit metrics,
we consider this
a true positive.
However, if we're
calculating the metrics
for another intent
called a payment posting,
we consider this
a true negative.
Because we did not expect to
get the intent payment posting,
and we did not get back
the intent payment posting.
And that's the definition
of what a true negative is.
For the purposes of our
individual intent metrics,
this is not as important,
but we still notate it--
the true negative, that is.
Let's say for another
message a customer said,
it shows my payment posted,
but I have no credit available.
Just wondering when
it will be available.
If Dialogflow detected
this as payment posting,
but we expected to get the
intent available credit,
then while we're calculating
available credit metrics,
we consider this
a false negative.
But conversely, for
payment posting,
we consider this
a false positive.
So once we're done
with this process,
we then calculate a set
of more advanced metrics
that can give us
some better insights.
The first one is
known as precision,
or positive predictive value.
We can use this to
determine if we have
problems with false positives.
And really, it's defined as
the total number of tests
where a specific
intent was detected.
For example, available credit.
What percentage of
those were correct?
Another intent known as
recall or sensitivity
or true positive
rate can be defined
as the total number
of tests where
a specific intent was expected.
For example, available credit.
What percentage of those
were detected correctly
as available credit?
And this will let us know if our
intent is too narrowly defined,
missing messages that
it's intended to pick up.
So you're using our simple data
set from the previous slide.
We would end up with
a precision of 100%,
but a recall of only 50%
for available credit.
So really, these two metrics are
complementary for the purposes
of measuring performance.
Precision can be 100% with
only one true positive
if we had no false positives.
But if recall isl low
for the same intent,
it really means it's missing
almost all messages entirely.
It doesn't really
provide much value.
Recently we've actually started
calculating a new metric called
F1 score, which is the harmonic
average of both precision
and recall.
As the number of intents
has grown and became
more cumbersome to look at
so many different metrics,
so the F1 score
provides a single number
that we can look at to look
at our intent performance.
So comparing a couple intents
seems easy enough, right?
But what happens when you
scale to 10, 50, 100 intents?
This is where a tool known
as a confusion matrix
can really come in handy.
Using the output data
from our test process,
we can generate essentially
a heat map of the intent
detection performance.
We map the detected
intent along the rows
and the expected
intent in the columns.
And in each cell is
the percentage of times
where those intents meet.
So if you see the dark line
from the top left diagonal down
the middle to the
bottom right, this
is where the detected and
the expected intents match.
And this is what we want to see.
Basically, the lighter
shade means less confusion,
or less times they meet.
And a darker shade you really
want to see in the middle.
So anytime we see a darker
shade outside of that middle
is where we have
areas of opportunity.
So for example here,
I've highlighted
an intent called unrecognized
transaction that's
been detected 19% of the
time when we really expect
to get pending transaction.
So what can we do
when we see this?
There's a few different things.
One of them is we need to
go down into the training
phases for each of these intents
and look for similarities
that we can try to eliminate.
Second thing that
we could try to do
is actually adjust the
confidence threshold.
Perhaps if we
increased it, there
could be less false positives
for unrecognized transaction.
Lastly, you might just need
to combine these two intents
into a single intent
and then build
the conversation
flows out to direct
the user down the right path.
So now I'll touch a little
bit on the Dialogflow agents
that we use.
Similar to common software
engineering practices
where you have different
development test production
environments, we do
a similar structure
for our Dialogflow agents.
And our development and
training environment
is where all of our
updates happen manually
either via the Dialogflow
console or via some processes
that we built out via API
calls that they provide
to update the training phrases.
When we're ready to promote
to the next environment,
we can execute a
deployment pipeline
that exports from development
to our staging environment.
Here, we can perform
acceptance testing
and run some regression
tests before confident enough
to deploy to production,
where we actually extract out
the entire configuration
into an artifact
that we've sent into
artifact repository.
And we execute another
pipeline to deploy that
into our production environment.
There's never any manual updates
happening into production.
It's all through processes
that are automated.
Being a finance institution,
we're highly regulated.
Having auditable processes
that are repeatable
is really important.
So expanding a little bit
upon the pipeline I just
talked about, this is something
that our business product
owners can initiate
and manage themselves.
It runs through all the tests
and the metric generation
that I've talked about.
And it compares the metrics
against the prior version.
So you can actually see
where things have improved.
Or you may have
introduced some issues.
And then it actually generates
a summary report for you
that will highlight
the changes for you,
instead of having to
go search for them.
So while the engineering team
has built out this process,
It's something that a business
or product owner can easily
execute and interpret
the results themselves.
So now I'd like to give a
quick demo of this process.
And full disclosure here,
this is a pre-recorded demo.
I want to be risk averse
and also cut out a couple
minutes from the middle.
So right now, I'm logged
into the Dialogflow web
console here, updating
our training agent.
And I'm editing the
intent, available credit.
Here's the training
phrase section.
So what I'm actually
going to do here
is the phrase that we saw
earlier, my example that got
detected as payment
posting, even though I'm
going against my own
advice, I'm going
to go ahead and add this
as a training phase,
knowing that it's
in a testing set.
And I should see a
performance improvement,
I would hope, right?
So let's go ahead and add that.
We'll save the changes.
I'm going to hop over
to another tab here.
This is actually an
internal web tool
that we've built out for
our business product owners
to help manage our
virtual assistant.
They can do a number of
things from this tool.
And one of them is actually
run the deployment pipeline.
Oops.
So here, we're going to go
ahead and select the source
as the training agent.
And we're going to deploy
that to our staging agent.
And once we kick off
the deployment here,
we get a message saying
our job has started.
I'm going to hop over to our
continuous integration server,
and just go ahead and explain
some of the steps that
are going on here.
So one of the first
things that we do
is we export the source agent.
Dialogflow provides
an API we can actually
extract the entire
configuration into a zip.
So we do that for the
source and the target.
And then we perform
some validation tests.
This is mostly just to
look at the content.
Dialogflow provides a
capability to set up
a custom payload
for your responses,
that we use dynamic
slots for user data.
So we're just doing some
schema validation there
to make sure it's well formed.
The next thing that we
do is actually generate
a difference report.
So basically, any
intents that were added,
anything where training
phases were updated
or any content
that's changed, we're
going to list out all the
changes that have happened.
Sometimes if there's
multiple people that
are updating the agent,
we want to make sure
that we list out
all the changes,
and we have that documented.
Next thing that we do is
think about those unit
tests in software engineering.
Certain phrases we
want to make sure that
are always detected
as specific intents,
so we make sure that those pass.
If not, they're going
to fail the deployment.
Next thing that we do is
run through all the tests
and metrics that
I've talked about.
And then we actually perform
a threshold validation,
making sure that all our
metrics at least meet
a minimum standard, or else,
we'll fail the deployment.
So after that's done, we'll
get a Slack notification
to our team channel.
Here our product owners can
then go ahead and check out
the results.
We send a link that they
can go ahead and download.
And we actually
require an approval,
so obviously, we want to
check the results out first
before they approve
the actual deployment.
So here, I'm going to go
download our difference report
and hopefully that we see
just one change was made.
And here, we can see intent
changed, available credit,
and here's the training
phase that I added.
So that's good.
Now we'll go into our
test evidence folder.
Here, we can see there's
a confusion matrix.
There's the test
metrics and the raw test
results, every single
message and what
it was detected as if we
want to investigate it.
Not that we do it every
time, but it's there.
So I'm going to go ahead and
download the summary report.
And here we can see,
OK, the precision
increased for payment posting.
That's good, less
false positives there.
But it looks like the
precision decreased
for a couple of other intents
that it wasn't expecting.
The recall did go up
for available credit.
So that's good.
True positives went up there.
But the recall
actually went down
for a number of other intents.
So it's pretty interesting.
Really, kind of
what this highlights
is machine learning AI's
not really an exact science.
You can't always expect
something's going
to work out the way it is.
And just having a
process like this
that we can automate
really helps us
to enable to do this at scale.
OK, you can click back.
All right, so now that we've
deployed to production,
how do we monitor
our performance
and continue to improve it?
So within our internal
web tool, we've
actually built a process
where we can view the messages
and what they were detected as.
We can go ahead
and annotate those
as either correct or incorrect.
And if they were wrong,
what was the right intent?
This allows us to do a
couple of different things.
One of them is actually
generate the performance metrics
of our real production
model, right?
It's one thing to be able to
look at in a test environment,
saying, OK, this is
how we should do.
But it's much more valuable
to see how you're actually
doing in production.
Second thing that
we do is actually
create an automated
process, where
we can export some
of these messages
into our test environment.
Let's say a message was detected
at a very little confidence
threshold, but that
was the correct intent.
We can go ahead and try to
add that to our development
environment to see how it
improves the performance.
Lastly, we can
generate something
that's known as an ROC curve.
Here we plot the
false positive rate
along the x-axis and
the true positive rate
along the y-axis for varying
confidence thresholds.
So for example here,
I've highlighted
at an 80% confidence
minimum threshold,
I can expect to get about
a 3.9% false positive rate
and a [INAUDIBLE]
true positive rate.
So circling back to
my previous slide
in confidence, if we had our
minimum threshold set at 80%,
we wouldn't be able to collect
any of this data to the right.
So by setting our confidence
low, collecting the data,
we can analyze it and make
a more informed decision
about how we want to set
our confidence thresholds.
Otherwise, you're
just taking a guess.
So talking a little
bit about how
we utilize this data in
production, our high level
process--
basically, when we're
receiving incoming messages,
we first go to Dialogflow,
detect the intent,
and get back a confidence score.
Part of our business
logic is then, one,
looking to see if we had
that intent enabled, and two,
if it meets the minimum
conference threshold.
We enable the
conference threshold
to be set on a
per attempt basis.
And if one's not set,
we use a global default.
So now you might be
asking, why would you have
an intent enabled or disabled?
Why are you going to have
that in your Dialogflow agent?
And there's a number of
different reasons for this.
One of them is if you
have something deployed
and you see an
issue with it, being
able to quickly turn it off is
something that is useful to us.
You can say, why not just
delete the intent of Dialogflow?
But as we've seen, making
updates to your model
can have unintended
consequences.
Second thing that
it allows us to do
is actually deploy new
intents to a smaller
number of channels.
We can actually
control these settings
at a per channel basis.
So we have a channel where
only employees can access.
So sometimes we'll beta test
the new intent in a channel
where only employees will
see it before rolling it out
to the broader public.
And the last thing
that we can actually do
is define intents
that we're either not
ready to fulfill yet,
or we just don't have
an intent desire to fulfill.
This can deflect away from
giving incorrect responses.
One example might be
for an intent increasing
the user's credit limit.
Let's say that somebody comes
in, and we see them ask,
I want to decrease
my credit limit.
I mean, this isn't
a common request.
So if this was detected as the
increase credit limit intent,
it's going to end up with
a bad user experience.
So by quickly
defining a new intent
to decrease credit
limit, we can go ahead
and get that detected, but
then route it to an agent
to handle it so it has a
better customer experience.
And with that, I'll go ahead
and turn it over to Price
to wrap things up here.
[APPLAUSE]
PRICE VETTER: So yeah, just
some of our key takeaways,
some of our learnings
over the past year--
when we started
this process, it was
really we needed to tackle kind
of the preconceived notions
that people think of when
AI is brought to bear.
So tackle this head on,
bring examples of what
AI is in their everyday lives.
And that will really
help people understand
that it's not this monster
under the bed kind of thing.
When we defined
our processes for--
taking in intents and really
defining the customer value,
the value for us as a
business, and all the way
through production
into post-production,
and being able to
train and improve
that experience post-launch.
We really didn't
reinvent the wheel there.
We leaned on existing processes.
We used metrics
from other channels,
so that when we were talking
about the virtual assistant,
it wasn't confusing
everybody in the room.
Big for us-- be
customer focused.
And John mentioned this earlier.
We were able to introduce
new intents that were not
necessarily fulfilling to get
the customer to a customer
service expert as
fast as possible
and not get them stuck in this
loop of, did you mean this?
Did you mean that?
Just really trying to
provide the best customer
experience possible is
really what has helped us
through this process.
And then the last two
kind of go together.
Enabling the business to get the
insights and the data they need
to deploy this at scale, using
it to deploy new intents,
make changes on the fly when
it comes to the confidence
thresholds that we use,
changing the kind of language
that the virtual assistant
uses and that the customer sees
when they're communicating
with a virtual assistant
is really important to us.
And so being able to do that at
scale is really crucial for us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]